année près de champagnole la classe de
cm1 cm2 est incollable en matière
d'instruction civique l'instituteur a
profité des élections pour renforcer le
programme des futurs citoyens qui en
savent déjà très long vous allez le voir
écouter plus tôt l'un d'entre eux a
expliqué le scrutin des régionales on va
pour des listes après le vote toutes
celles qui n'ont pas à 5% et sans
éliminer on additionne le nombre de voix
qu'elle avait on les soustrait aux
nombres dessus or nombre de suffrages
exprimés
voilà divise au nombre de conseillers
régionaux qui devrait y avoir dans le
département alors après on obtient
crucien on divise le monde de voix des
listes qui ne sont pas éliminés par ce
quotient san cela donne le nombre d'élus
vous saviez tout ça vous moi pas en tout
cas nicolas lui a tout compris avec sa
classe ils ont exceptionnellement deux
heures d'un sursaut civique par semaine
est un marche droit maintenant les
attributions du conseil régional
maintenant que les conseillers régionaux
sont élus
que font-ils les domaines d'action de la
région sont les aménagements du
territoire les logements les transports
l'éducation les formation
professionnelle et apprentissage
environnement action que cols au
programme la commune le département la
région avec à chaque fois des visites
sur place
les élus font quelques des murs on va
manger très bien participer un peu pour
aider la commune utile d'apprendre par
points parce que comme ça si nos enfants
plus tard d'une demande en saura sans
atout voir passionnel
bien son physique et puis les jets tout
en voulez savoir comment ça se passe et
des directions une carrière politique
nicolas ne dit pas non et bien pour
avoir une une odieuse france habilités
pour être aussi un petit peu connu et
puis aussi prendre part aux décisions
ici pas de débat d'idées l'objectif est
de comprendre comment se déroule la vie
politique dont à titre personnel est
sûre j'ai visité mais ne transparaissent
pas vous l'avez constaté donc ce travail
je pense que le but c'est de montrer des
réalités uniquement dans le domaine
chimique aux enfants des enfants qui
pourraient bien dimanche tiré leurs
parents par la manche pour qu'ils
aillent voter